[Music]
this is a real thrill for me one of my
oldest friends and one of the funniest
guys I know big Jay oakerson thanks so
much for being here
thank you for having me man I feel good
about that shake do you feel good about
it it was fantastic it was from and
friendly you say you knew me when I was
very young I just moved to New York I
was still married yeah
very kind of for lack of a better term
Mormon nominee seeming you know I
remember your ex-wife the TUC futures
very sweet but very uh you met her yes
but I remember like I think she wanted
you not to hang out with me more because
I think like you brought around and I
think I was going to go some kind of
horrible philandering myself like I'm
separated now and you were doing some
Flandre some real philandering I think
she walked in right in the middle of
some Flint now you know physical like
yeah yeah nothing second tale it's like
hanging out and it was like kind of like
I think she probably gave you the old
like uh is that his wife no it's not
public she wanted you to have to hang
out PT well she actually said something
I remember at the time this is so weird
to say I remember the time I was like I
am struggling with pornography I didn't
tell my wife I'm so [__] weird I was
like 24 years old I was like I want to
let you know a struggle of money
adult film sino to me help me with this
yeah yeah keep me accountable and you on
the other hand would we were at the
cellar one night when we walked to a
newsstand and you asked the the guy at
the bodega to just give you the most
recent barely legal you flipped through
it I was gonna buy it blind you handed
it back and didn't buy it
wasn't I think not good
I'm going young girl I need Bush I gotta
know she's a woman I'm gonna say and
this has probably been said before I
missed the days of when pornography
would be like a more special thing the
the woods under our Rock the problem
with pornography now is that it's
everywhere among other things especially
the father - I think you know there's
like gonna say you have a daughter yeah
and I have a daughter which I feel some
bad karma coming from this we were
talking at some point just buckle up
[Music]